des célébrations sans précédent pour un
triomphe historique pas de travail pas
d'école c'est une journée fériée pour
les amateurs des raptors parce que je
vais revoir mes préférés sur l'autobus
et je veux c'est vrai avec mes amis
aujourd'hui pour nous c'est vraiment une
à une moment l'histoire je croise pour
la vie pour la paix pour lesparre nous
sommes tellement contents qu'ils
allaient rater avec telly dans une foule
monstre deux millions de personnes selon
les autorités
des automobilistes s'arrêtent même au
beau milieu de l'autoroute surélevé
qu'un des leurs pour voir les champions
le cortège tente de se frayer un chemin
dans la marée humaine
aucune barrière n'a été installé pour
contenir la foule
c'est comme si les autorités n'avaient
pas prévu le coup pour ce premier défilé
d'une équipe sportive majeure au pays
depuis 1993 les joueurs n'en croient pas
leurs yeux
[Applaudissements]
et rien que pendant que le cortège peine
encore à avancer
les incidents se multiplient des parents
ont perdu leurs enfants dans la foule
des personnes déshydratées ont perdu
conscience
malgré tout la fête continue ses joueurs
célébrée pour leur diversité ont fait
vibrer un pays entier le temps est venu
de les remercier
oui westin son match we want it all
again
le premier ministre trudeau leur demande
même de répéter l'exploit l'an prochain
la supervedette kawaii l'honneur l'agent
libre dans quelques semaines reçoit les
clés de la ville de toronto au nom de
ses coéquipiers
la ville leur appartient depuis leur
victoire jeudi soir
[Applaudissements]
soudain un mouvement de foule la panique
des coups de feu ont éclaté
au moins quatre personnes ont été
blessées grièvement mais on ne craint
pas pour leur vie
les policiers ont arrêté trois suspects
[Musique]
après une brève suspension les
festivités continuent le maître de
cérémonie des raptors implorent les
partisans de se rappeler pourquoi ils
sont réunis pour se réjouir pour
communier avec leur équipe
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et pour célébrer leur extraordinaire
champions
[Applaudissements]